so you were just talking about the
people that sort of you started with and
then slowly some of them stay and some
of them go in terms of making films it
almost reminds me of a line and it might
have been Edith's IV in followed who
talks about the strong will rise in the
weak will falter and that this is a
harsh look at social and economic
structures but it's similar to nature
and nature is harsh and I thought I'm
sort of paraphrasing here but I thought
that was a great line and I'm not sure
if it's her okay so it almost reminds me
of a filmmaking Darwinism basically and
so when you say this really if we were
to label some strong and some weak and I
realize that sort of a harsh statement
there but when it comes to filmmaking
what would you term the weak and what
would you term the strong that is a very
good question actually I hadn't really
thought about that before but you're
you're exactly right it's not harsh it's
reality there are people that are strong
and there are people that are weak the
difference is as a filmmaker if you're
trying to determine what makes a strong
room and what makes a weak one I think
what it really has to do with is people
that see their career as a short-term
thing and a long-term thing and that is
the differentiator when you make a
project it's not just about that project
if you're thinking long-term it's
thinking about how is this project going
to enable me to make the next thing and
then the thing after that and then the
thing after that it's about climbing
that ladder ascending the staircase
because each piece that you make
assuming that you do a good job and
people like it will enable you to do
something else different in the future
but if you see your career as a
short-term game if you just see it as oh
I have to make this project you make
that project and then you have no idea
what you're going to make next what kind
of film you want to make next or if you
can identify what kind of films you like
to make as I said earlier for me I'm
drawn to films that are about loss and
identity if you're a filmmaker that
can't say very succinctly what kind of
projects you make no one will take you
seriously because they don't know what
to hire you for so it's very important I
think if you want to perceive yourself
as being a strong maker film maker to
not only have
an identity for the kind of films you
like to make but also have a play and a
progression for which you wish to jump
off so let's take two filmmakers
filmmaker a and B both of them that both
both works are amazing incredibly
creative people talented different
things like that but what would be the
tell-tale signs that one is probably
going to fall off in some sense and the
other one's going to keep going I think
that the tell-tale signs honestly have
to do if your motivation a lot of
filmmaking is stamina and and if you're
in the middle of production and you're
already exhausted or tired of the film
that you're doing I'm always astounded
when I talk to filmmakers who are in
post-production on a film and they're
talking about oh I can't wait for this
to be finished
I understand editing is hard filmmaking
is a hard long strenuous journey but
when you aren't engaged or involved in
the process that you're actively
involved with and that can be in
post-production and production and prep
or even in publicizing the film that
you're making you're not going to make
it as a filmmaker because it's about
that long journey
it may take you three or four years to
make a feature film and I don't mean
shoot it I mean develop it shoot it edit
it publicize it release it it's a
multi-step process and I think that that
is the indicator of if you're going to
make it or not if you can make it across
each of the finish lines not just one
right and not tire east and not tire
easily you've got to constantly be
fighting if you're not an advocate for
your own film no one else will be right
were there times we're where you were
tested in that you wondered is this
really for me and then you got back on
course because there are a lot of things
that are surprising everyone thinks Oh
being on set yeah it's going to be a
long day but it's cool and you feel you
know whatever the important glamorous
but then those long hours in the editing
Bay or problem-solving
you know things aren't working out
something's wrong with the film like the
actual physical you know what
the mechanics of the project were there
times where you were tested and then you
had to sort of like write yourself
I think there's unless someone has some
incredible piece of luck I think that on
every film there's a moment where you
question yourself you question can I do
this do I had the capacity to do this
thing and what separates you from other
filmmakers if you're successful is that
you have the capacity to troubleshoot
and and get past the roadblock it may
have to do with a location perhaps
you're filming somewhere in a location
doesn't work the way that you thought it
was going to work perhaps someone's late
perhaps an actor's having a meltdown
that happens on film sets I've had
experience with that before you can't
stop the entire production because any
of those things happen you have to
figure out a way to chart a course
forward because especially when you're
working in independent film you don't
have the resources nor the time to stop
because something doesn't work and so I
think for most filmmakers if you want to
identify and even for me you've got to
be able to say okay here is my problem
here are some outcomes if this thing
doesn't work out the way I think it does
and what path is going to be the best
way for me to fix the problem and that's
what you've always got to do so for me
it's always been I've never had a moment
where oh I don't want to do film or this
is not for me but I have certainly had
moments where I have questioned my
capacity to do them but what's I think
made me successful professionally is
being able to figure out what the
solutions are I know there's a term in
self-help it's called low frustration
tolerance which I think all of us suffer
from from time to time
it sounds like being able to move
through like these tedious things that
really would get a lot of people down
sounds like the secret to a lot of it
because a lot of people I hear they give
up it's over some incident that happened
and they say you know what forget it
this is
done with it well I I think about my
grandmother a lot and her my my
grandmother died a few years ago but one
of the things that she always used to
say about her husband with grandfather
is that she never went to bed angry with
him and whether or not that was true or
not in their 60 years of marriage that I
don't know while that doesn't
necessarily apply to everyone I think
that it certainly can be applied to your
professional career not just your
personal life and so for me if I get
frustrated or angry as we all do on a
film set it may be with the person
you're working with it could be an actor
it could be a producer it could be
someone on your crew if you get a bed
angry with them and if you hold on to
that anger it's very easy to lose sight
of the big picture and so for me I think
you almost have to take the Zen approach
to say happens you do it you deal
with it and then you move on from it
because if you're constantly holding on
to the bed you can't focus on the good
you